Do I need to be on the new supplements you suggested for the genetics or a life?
Well
Baby, yeah, so your genetics aren't gonna change. So
If you're if you're taking
Let's say I suggested the curcument. Let's pretend for because of your genetics
It's because of your genetics that I suggested the curcument. So
Your genetics aren't gonna change even if your cancer is all God and you're doing fantastic
You still have those genes
And that curcument that I suggested is based upon that the gene is not based upon your cancer. It's based upon your genes
So yes, but does it mean you have to take them the rest?
You're like, no, nothing. You don't have to do anything. You don't want to do it. Okay, but if you want to support that
Genetic family that you have issues with, then
That is the best way to support it. So
What if I just need a whole bunch of curcument things and okay, well, then maybe don't have to take curcument that day. So
It's it doesn't mean you have to do everything every day either, but in general, yes, those genes are
gonna change so
In general, yeah, your genes are gonna be the same and you're gonna want to support those pathways